Order surrounded by chaos,
right?
It's like a tree.
It's like the the,
the evolutionary home of primates,
the tree with the snakes on the ground.
That's,
that's our landscape or it's the fire
for tribal people and the terrors of the
forest that are beyond the,
that are beyond the.
The light that the fire casts.
It's explored territory versus
unexplored territory and that's,
that's an archetype as well that you
can't not be in a situation where that's
the case.
Even if you're among friends,
you know,
you think that's explored territory.
That's not exactly right because what
happens if you're among friends is that
they carefully reveal new parts of
themselves all the time.
So it's like they're blasting little
elements of unexplored territory.
You territory at you constantly and if
they don't,
then what happens?
You get bored and you look for New
People and we know there's empirical
data on that with regards to intimate
relationships because there was a nice
study done awhile back showing that
looking at the ratio of positive to
negative emotional experiences that were
most predictive of long term
relationship success.
And the answer was,
you know,
obviously it depends on how you would
measure an event and how you would
measure positive and negative emotion.
But that aside,
the finding was something like if you're
in a relationship and you only have five
positive interactions to one negative
interaction,
then the relationship will end.
It's too negative.
But if you have more than 11 positive
interactions to one negative
interaction,
then it also ends and you think,
well that's pretty bloody peculiar.
Wha why in the world would that be?
Don't you want like a hundred to one
positive to negative interactions and
answer to that is what makes you think
that you wanted to relationship so that
you can be happy or at least happy
moment to moment.
What?
Why do you think that it's not?
It's certainly not the case is that you
know that too because you.
I'm,
I mean I bet you there's not a person in
this room who hasn't rejected someone
because they were too nice to them.
Something like that person's no
challenge.
It's something like that.
You want someone who you know you can
get along with them,
but now and then they bite you and you
think,
oh,
that's,
that's interesting.
You know I didn't really expect that,
and then you go and puzzle over it for
awhile and you torture yourself about it
and that's one of the things that keeps
you really linked into the relationship
and the reason for that is that part of
the reason that you want the
relationship isn't so that you're happy
right now so that you can live a high
quality life across multiple decades and
so you're looking for someone that you
have to contend with who's going to push
you beyond what you already are and
who's going to judge you harshly often
for your limitations.
Now that'll make you angry and all of
that,
you know,
and resentful and maybe you'll take your
revenge and and,
and all of that,
but you don't want someone who thinks
you're perfect in your current foreign.
Partly because why would you want to go
out with someone that diluted.